Німеччина - країна експорту.
Утім, німецька мова поки продається не на ура.
ад іміджем німецької мови, судячи з усього,
ще слід попрацювати.
Це дуже складна мова
Дуже сувора мова,
звучить як військовий наказ.
На слух надто жорстка,
я б навіть сказав, дуже різка мова.
І все ж популярність німецької мови
останніми роками помітно зросла. Курси німецької
в Гете-Інституті користуються великим попитом.
Німецька вважається четвертою за популярністю
іноземною мовою після англійської,
французької та китайської.
Лінгвіст Ульріх Аммон вивчає поширення німецької мови у світі
і написав про це книгу.
Нині спостерігається зростання
авторитету німецької мови у світі.
І головна причина - економічна стабільність країни.
Саме це відбивається на решті факторів.
У тому числі на інтересі до німецької культури.
Зі знанням мови більше шансів влаштуватися на роботу
в якусь світову німецьку компанію.
Спортивні досягнення, приміром успіхи
німецької збірної з футболу, теж підігрівають
інтерес до Німеччини.
І звісно ж, Берлін. Німецька столиця -
модне європейське місто, популярне серед молоді.
Тому так багато охочих пройти курс
німецької мови саме в Берліні.
Ось яке у них враження від німецької.
Я би сказала так:
німецька - гарна мова, але дуже складна для вивчення.
Я завжди кажу, що опанувати
досконало німецьку у мене не вийде,
але я буду працювати над цим.
Так, це дуже складна мова, дуже жорстка на слух та сприйняття.
Вони ніби кричать, говорять голосно та різко.
На початку я не могла вимовляти літеру «р».
Я тренувалася вранці і ввечері,
набираючи в рот води після чищення зубів.
Німецький рок-гурт «Рамштайн»
багато в чому саме завдяки звучанню німецької
досяг успіху.
І «Рамштайн», до речі, теж сприяє інтересу молоді
до вивчення німецької.
Хітом у ютьюбі став кліп,
в якому іноземці порівнюють звучання одного і того ж слова
у різних мовах, включно з німецькою.
Судячи з усього, вчити німецьку хоча й складно,
але дуже весело.